-Performing "More than a Love
Song" from their new album,
"Chronicles of a Diamond,"
please welcome Black Pumas!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Ah-oh ♪
♪ Right on, babe ♪
♪ Right on, daughter ♪
♪ For now till forevermore ♪
♪ See the two black birds
flying ♪
♪ Flying hiiiiiiiigh ♪
♪ Just to be together ♪
♪ When we face the music ♪
♪ Might help you to the other
side of a great divide ♪
♪ Fly together ♪
♪ Ask the grand master why ♪
♪ I've asked him why life
feels so hard sometimes ♪
♪ You got the muse, the music,
sweet soul music ♪
♪ To reignite your soul,
to reignite your soul ♪
♪ Because life is more,
more than a love song ♪
♪ It's more than a fantasy,
more than a little bit ♪
♪ This life is more than
a dream, y'all ♪
♪ It's more than a fantasy,
more than a little bit ♪
♪ So take your time,
realize life goes by ♪
♪ Fly way up higher ♪
♪ Let's fly, touch that sky ♪
♪ Together, babe ♪
-♪ Fly, fly high ♪
-♪ See the two blue birds
sing that song ♪
♪ Do-do-do-do, do-do-do-do,
yeah, babe ♪
♪♪
♪ My respects to the grand
master for the lines ♪
♪ Such a pretty thing
how the melody abides ♪
♪ 'Cause life is more,
more than a love song ♪
♪ It's more than a fantasy,
more than a little bit ♪
♪ This life is more than
a dream, y'all ♪
♪ It's more than a fantasy,
more than a little bit ♪
♪ Life is more,
more than a love song ♪
♪ It's more than a fantasy,
more than a little bit ♪
♪ I'm through the door now,
see the sun shining ♪
♪ Way more,
more than a little bit ♪
♪ So let's walk through the door
together, baby ♪
-♪ Fly ♪
-♪ Holding hands ♪
♪ And love will save me ♪
-♪ Fly high ♪
-♪ Black Pumas ♪
♪ Can somebody help me sing,
yeah? ♪
♪ Oh, life is more, way more ♪
♪ I'm way up high nooooow ♪
♪ Why when the thunder sounds ♪
♪ And you see the lightning
almost touch the ground ♪
♪ You hear a voice sometimes,
my inner child loves to sing ♪
♪ Fly together ♪
-♪ Fly together ♪
-♪ Life feels so hard sometimes,
you start to lose your mind ♪
♪ Just grab your sister's hand
and let's fly ♪
-♪ Fly together ♪
-♪ Fly way up high ♪
♪ Just you and me, ladies ♪
♪ Come on ♪
♪ Let's fly together ♪
-♪ Fly together ♪
-♪ Let's fly together ♪
-♪ Touch the sky together,
baby ♪
♪ Oh, together now ♪
-♪ Fly together ♪
-♪ Let's fly together, darling ♪
-♪ Let's fly together ♪
-♪ Fly together ♪
-♪ Help me sing the song ♪
-♪ Fly ♪
-♪ Fly together ♪
-♪ Touch that sky ♪
-♪ Let's fly together ♪
-♪ Fly together ♪
-♪ Let's fly right on ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]